Spring cleaning is in the air and I am hot to trot.
It's why I'm so excited to share with you
a company I have been working with.
I was first a customer before I actually became a partner,
and now our show is working with them too.
They are called Grove Co.
And all of their household products
are sustainably powerful.
And they have 100% natural fragrances, no harsh chemicals.
And by 2025, they will be completely plastic-free,
they are almost already there.
(audience clapping)
They actually have a whole recycling program.
And this is absolutely my favorite product.
This multipurpose cleaning spray is a game changer,
and it comes in this gorgeous bottle.
And even the refills come in these little baby
glass bottles that I love so much.
Again, no plastic.
So you would take your bottle of water,
and then you add in the cleaning solution
and their scents.
Oh God, so good.
Their scents are so beautiful.
And then, what you wanna do is I actually buy
their bamboo toilet paper,
'cause I wanna like save a tree.
And they make paper towels at of bamboo as well.
But these are actually my new favorite,
the European dishcloth,
because what you do is when you wet it,
it's so much more powerful than a paper towel,
it's like a shammy and you use them and they're great.
They're absorbent, they're malleable.
And then, you can pop 'em in the washer and voila,
no paper or trees wasted either.
(audience clapping)
I know.
But I have to tell you that another way
that Grove educated me is they have something
I haven't seen from any other company.
These are laundry detergent sheets, so no plastic.
It's amazing.
They're so effective you put them in with your clothes.
Voila, everything comes out perfect.
It makes me feel so good about the way I'm living my life.
And I just believe in this company so much
and they are the solution that I wanna share with you guys.
Another thing that I'm highly addicted
to is fabric softener,
so I found these wool dryer balls.
Now you can just put one in per load,
but I want that effect
that really good fabric softener does.
And these have it,
and they're totally eco and they're amazing,
and they really get the job done.
And once, again, I'm like, "I am living that life.
I am walking the walk, and I'm talking the talk,
and it empowers me, and it puts a smile on my face."
I'm so excited and passionate
to share this information with you.
And the truth is you are all gonna go home
with these dryer balls and laundry sheets,
so that you can do this and we can all do it together!
Literally!
We can all make small changes
this month to be more sustainable.
And these are the products I use in my home
because they are so earth-friendly,
and beautiful, and effective.
And everything at grove.com is amazing
and you should go shop it.
It's got a very diverse portfolio
of products that they sell, including their own line.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)